and yeah and this one's going to blow
your mind I saw this one yesterday this
is just incredible do you know this is
true labels and jelly spoons this is
totally true that the CDC the Center for
Disease Control is still recommending
masks on two-year-olds now and they
refuse to reverse it so Rochelle
wolenski who is uh in charge of the CDC
she was testifying yesterday in front of
Congress still defending this concept I
do want to mention one thing I told you
guys when we went to DC a couple months
back that I was walking they have the
tunnel I think that goes between what
was it between the capital and the uh
where the where Congress the
Congressional offices basically so
there's this underground tunnel we're
walking through the tunnel and I walked
right by walensky like we basically
touched shoulders and there was
something about her I kid you not we all
looked at each other like she does not
seem human she might be some sort of
lizard person News Guard you can check
me on that one because I'm pretty sure
we'll find something very disturbing and
cold blooded anyway here's cdc's
Rochelle wilinski defending masks on
two-year-olds yesterday in fact the CDC
is currently the only National or
International public health agency that
recommends masking two-year-old children
I'd like you to explain in detail the
process in the timeline by which
evidence such as this is used by the CDC
to update modify or necessary withdraw
current guidance great thank you for the
opportunity to clarify on those points
so I believe you're referring to the
Cochrane review study this is an
important study but the Cochrane review
only includes randomized clinical trials
and as you can imagine many of the
randomized clinical trials that were
included in that were for other
respiratory viruses not covet 19. some
of them were for covid-19 just to be
clear but it is very different for
covid-19 because you have a pre-advirus
that a different from flu potentially
different from SARS or MERS transmits
before you actually have symptoms it's
also the case that one of the
limitations in that study was clearly
stated that people were not actually
engaged in the intervention so you
actually have to wear the mask for it to
work okay so there are lots of studies
now in Georgia why are we masking our
kids today you know thank you also so
our guidance for school-based masking is
related to our covid-19 Community levels
and fortunately we're in a place now in
this country where most of our country
is in green or yellow has a lower low or
moderate transmission or covid-19
Community levels and in those situations
we actually don't recommend masking we
recommend it for high covid-19
communities so what is your timeline for
updating reevaluating these guide
guidance you know our masking guidance
doesn't really change with time what it
changes with is disease so when there's
a lot of disease in a community we
recommend that those communities and
those schools mask When there's less
disease in the community we recommend
that those masks even come off so okay
so it's just going to continue
your abject nonsense now I hope and I
know if you're watching this show you
are no longer listening to the CDC and
you should not
you don't have to listen to me you
should make whatever choices are right
for you and your family and everything
else I can tell you I got two kids
downstairs uh both of whom are actually
a little under the weather right now and
David's a little under the weather too
we're running an infirmary here right
now I'm the only one operating 100 so
I'm gonna have a very crazy day after I
uh finish this there's gonna be a lot of
spit up all over me is what it is that's
just fine
um I am never putting masks I mean the
idea that you would put a mask on a
two-year-old because that crazy
dishonest
oh
[Music]
foreign